gpt4 is out four months after its
predecessor shook the internet the
algorithm which stands for generative
pre-trained Transformer is artificial
intelligence presented as a chat bot
it's a large language model fed enormous
volumes of data from the internet gpts
learn to generate Answers by predicting
how words should be arranged but humans
also take part this is where the model
learns what sounds normal and what
sounds odd misleading or dangerous the
company creates so-called guard rails to
prevent these
so what's new this time gpt4 understands
images users have taken photographs of
their refrigerators and asked the AI to
help them prepare dinner
it can write code an entrepreneur
describes the cell phone game Snake and
the AI helped him code it from scratch
in minutes
users are deploying it as a personal
assistant
it thinks of things that I don't think
of and that's the part that kind of
blows my mind the most I feel like it's
been making a lot of
um the things that I've been putting
together so much more insightful be my
eyes a startup called be my eyes
integrated it into software that
describes the world to visually impaired
users if you're a blind user uh you know
you you open the app up until today you
know we only have the option of calling
a volunteer and and doing a a video call
what you can do now is you you will use
the same app instead of calling a
volunteer you click a button to then go
into the new feature the virtual
volunteer you have a bag of pasta uh you
know in your kitchen and you want to
know which kind is it and what's the
cooking time right so you take a photo
and it will come back and say you need
to cook it nine to 11 minutes or
whatever it says
gpt4 may be ahead at the moment but it's
not alone Baidu the Chinese Tech Giant
rolled out a bot called Ernie
mid-journey is already used by
Architects to generate photorealistic
images from text prompts all this is
making some creative humans worried the
Society of illustrators published a
statement against the use of AI
generated art in competitions the U.S
copyright office denied protection to a
comic book illustrated by Ai and a
coding Hub is suing several AI companies
for plagiarism
the question now is for how long will
the judges be able to tell the
difference
Colin Baker Al Jazeera